who is the only Grandmaster to have
beaten both world champions in classical
chess this year in January Anish Geary
took on Magnus in round four of their
prestigious Tata steel masters with
superb peace coordination anise Twisted
magnus's pieces into knots and created
crippling pins in the center and after a
brilliant night maneuver it was all but
decided Anis earned his first classical
Victory against Magnus in 12 years and
with that Burning Flame went on to claim
first place in the 2023 Tata steel
Masters a few days ago in round seven of
the super bet chess classic Anish faced
new world champion ding Loren the tie
turned when Anish discovered a brilliant
night sacrifice that opened the
Champions King side while the game
wasn't won there anise did not let up
playing several great moves and grinding
out a result Anish finished that
tournament in a four-way tie per second
slaying Champions multiple times in one
year Anish Gary is a force to be
reckoned with only time will tell what's
next which answers the question